Before We Say Goodbye you have one last
word in the world of social media this
is what I'm
[Music]
liking November is National family
caregivers month which recognizes the 53
million people who provide care to an
elderly or disabled loved one it's
stressful and often isolating work
something author Debbie Weiss can relate
to for over 40 years she cared for her
father then her son and finally her
husband it's a story she shares in her
new book on second thought maybe I can
let's get Debbie in here everybody give
it up for
Debbie hi Debbie hi Kelly well thank you
for joining us and and I just have to
say you're you've been a caregiver your
whole life right my whole life you said
it 40 years I was thrust into caregiving
when I was 17 when my father at 46 had a
massive stroke became permanently
disabled and soon afterwards my parents
divorced and I became became his primary
caregiver for the next 30 Years and then
when my oldest son was two he was
diagnosed on the autistic spectrum and
added anxiety and depression a little
later on and more recently about 5 years
ago my husband became permanently
disabled and unfortunately passed away
on December 30th oh and I've spent the
majority of my life caring for others
and after many years I was exhausted
angry resentful and bitter and I hate to
admit it but I felt sorry for
myself and I then realized that I was
feeling this way because I neglected
myself for all those years and that
realization was a big game Cher for me
yeah so that change then created this
book right it has been a long journey
over the last 10 years that actually led
to the book yes absolutely what do you
hope people when they read it what do
you hope they get out of it oh goodness
well I hope they learn what I eventually
did that prioritizing your own care is
not selfish it's a necessity and when we
do that we actually show up as better
caregivers and just better people for
everyone else in our lives you know we
don't really have to choose between
ourselves and our loved ones we all have
the capacity to care for both absolutely
the I would say it's the oxygen mask
mentality when you're on the airplane
you know they always tell you okay put
yours on first and then help you know
your little ones and that's hard to
implement in life especially if you've
grown up with you know being told like
have a servant's heart always look out
for others and you always put yourself
aside it's kind of how I grew up as well
and it's hard to change to Pivot that
thank you so much Debbie I'm liking your
post right
now and that's not all ma'am our season
long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to erasable pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show love your support
for caregivers so on your behalf they're
riding family caregivers Alliance a
check for
$1,000 for more than 40 years this
organization has provided services and
support for caregivers like yourself so
thank you so much for putting them on
everybody's radar to pay attention
to thank you Debbie before we go I want
to remind you to watch The 91st
Christmas and Rockefeller Center
tomorrow night at 8 I am hosting and
we'll also be performing alongside a
star studded lineup uh it airs on NBC
and peacock so be sure to check it out
it's going to be incredible thanks to
all our guests this out everybody Mark
Harmon K Mitchell Aaron Zach and lenita
and Debbie of course y'all have a great
day and if it's not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home